good morning Hank it's Sunday yesterday
I was at the Indiana State Fair and I
got to see the world's largest boar he
weighs more than 1,100 pounds and he
can't stand up because his body is too
big for his tiny little legs and what
you ask is the name of the world's
largest bull er walk and tall get it
it's funny because he can't walk
Hank walking tall the world's largest
boar who can't walk reminded me a little
bit of America's health care system
depending on your perspective
he's either impressively huge or
distressingly huge
so what do you do when you have a pig
that's so big he can't walk you either
kill him put him on a diet or keep
feeding him which is more of us with the
health care debate boils down to so Hank
I want to talk in a non-partisan way
about the healthcare debate but I don't
want to scream and I don't want to act
like the people watching us have the
intellectual sophistication of
brain-damaged goldfish and mostly I
don't want to talk about death panels
because they're not in the bill and the
stupid unsophisticated debate about them
has distracted from a really large and
significant issue ok Hank so here are
two things that pretty much everyone
conservative or liberal agrees upon one
the United States spends way too much of
its gross domestic product on health
care and to our current health care
system is radically unfair I'm not
saying that other models wouldn't be
more unfair just that our current one is
unfair
whether you have good health care in
America is dependent largely on whether
you work for a big company because big
companies have to provide health
benefits and second whether you have a
pre-existing condition which a lot of
times isn't your fault some people argue
that we need a sort of large-scale
government-run insurance company the
so-called public option which everyone
would be able to buy into and poor
people would pay less than richer people
and then this huge government-run in
sherwood negotiate lower costs for
procedures and also cut down on the
number of procedures used now even
though the public option would not in
any way eliminate private insurers
private insurers still hate the public
option because they know that the
government-run insurance company will be
larger and therefore more able to
negotiate lower prices which will in
turn make the public insurance less
expensive which will make people less
inclined to use private insurance then
you have the people who want to put the
pigs on a diet who say that instead of a
public option we can create these sort
of nonprofit insurance companies that
will then have to compete with private
insurance and because they won't be
for-profit companies they'll be
incentivized not to work for the
shareholders in the company but instead
to work for the patients they represent
now of course the downside of the put
the pig on the diet plan is that you
still end up with tens of millions of
people who have no health insurance
whatsoever and then there are the people
who don't want a health care system
overhaul they want to keep feeding the
pig a lot of those people are happy with
the current state of their health care
and to be frank I think they probably
don't want to pay for people who make
stupid decisions and on some level heck
I can empathize with this because when I
was at the Indiana State Fair and I saw
chocolate covered bacon I thought to
myself geez I don't really want to be on
the financial hook for people who eat
chocolate-covered bacon
so hey
here's the underlying problem even
though a lot of people are screaming I
don't want socialism no socialism in
America right now we have a lot of
socialism we share the cost of schools
and roads and the military we also
currently have socialized medicine we
just have an outrageously bloated an
inefficient system of socialized
medicine because there are hospitals in
America where anyone can go and get
treatment that treatment may eventually
bankrupt you and it may be of poor
quality but you can get it and I would
argue that it is the inefficiency of our
socialized medicine that in the end
makes health care so much more expensive
than it is anywhere else in the world is
health care a privilege or is it a right
if it's a privilege even if it's a
really desirable privilege like indoor
plumbing we need to stop giving health
care of any kind to uninsured people who
can't pay for it in advance but Hank I
have to tell you I think the reason we
continue to treat people who are
uninsured is because we don't believe
that health care is a privilege we
believe that it is a right and if it is
a right like life liberty and the
pursuit of happiness it is the
responsibility of a government to
protect that right I'll see you on
Tuesday